all right is it real or is it memorex
soon you can one day buy your own
hologram device the company portal
has brought its uh devices and its magic
right here to las vegas and uh wow
i don't know is this a beam me up scotty
kind of thing hector what's going on
here
are you real well
just take a look at your screen uh the
question now is
is this the real hector or are you
taking a live look at
hologram hector i'll wait for the answer
but the answer is
that is hologram hector now it's first
time well this morning first time ever
reporting live via hologram version
we're about to conduct an interview we
do not have a mask because
i want to stress this a million times we
are safely distanced right now so this
interview we are doing
complements via hologram technology and
joining us live to explain what this is
all about we have chris chris italia
here
with illusion entertainment and
dreamland xr to explain
okay how soon can we see this out in the
streets or maybe inside a casino good
morning to you
hey hector welcome back so yeah portal
is got a lot of plans here in las vegas
one of which is
artificial reality which is our new day
and night club experience where we'll
have virtual djs and other performers
performing for both an online audience
and a real world audience so we're
getting into hybrid events now
how cool is this it's fantastic i feel
like i'm inside either a
vending machine or i don't know it just
looks so cool and it's lifelike too
it's so hd it's 4k absolutely yeah we
can see every detail on you
so it's good to be perfectly manicured
when you're in the portal
uh you're looking great by the way
[Laughter]
and it's so hd earlier where you could
see you know lit on my sweater
yes yes every detail is clearly defined
in hologram technology all right so who
right now is the ideal customer and how
much does something like this cost
well uh there's a different price range
but in general
uh we're doing rentals and both sales uh
so we
are going to be deploying into both
advertising models
entertainment also keep in mind
telepresence or telemedicine
so doctors could meet with patients
virtually and
a whole series of other things so we see
the obvious we're in a hologram form
but you know bigger picture how do you
think this is really going to change the
world
i think it already has in some regards
people are calling portal the new
amazon and referring it to
groundbreaking like google in the
beginning of the
internet so i think there's a lot of
things to come and
we'll have to stay tuned all right well
thank you so much for having us
reporting live hector hologram back to
you guys what do you guys think
i like your new moniker hector hologram
it's you know it's really trippy uh
maybe we could
we can incorporate that sherry and do
this job from home
well that is one way i mean you know we
a lot of us have been zooming
yeah maybe we could be hologramming yeah
for 4k
though that's a little too clear for me
i don't want to see anyone that clear
it's only going to get clearer alex
that's just the way
oh i don't know hector hologram sounds
like
he could have his own superhero cartoon
i know it
good job hector